my name is Jennifer Dewalt I am from San
Francisco California in the United
States and I taught myself to code by
making 180 websites and a hundred eighty
days javascript was the first
programming language that I really
learned through the hundred eighty
websites project and most of the
websites that I did in that project use
JavaScript very heavily although I did
use Ruby on Rails these days I do a lot
of hacks using node.js and client-side
JavaScript working with hardware so I
gave a talk about how I taught myself to
code by making 180 websites 180 days and
so I gave a little bit of a history of
myself I came from a small farming
community and ended up studying fine art
in school but after I graduated I
realized that I wasn't content with just
using all these amazing web and Internet
products that I actually want to start
building them myself so I decided I
wanted to learn to code and I decided to
do a self-directed project where I would
make one website a day every single day
for 180 days so in my talk I went
through a handful actually 40 of my
websites that I made during that project
starting from the very beginning and
going to the very end of the project
exploring things like the toys games
data visualizations tools and even real
time communication apps so recently I
have been working for a company called
wits at AI and we make an API that makes
it really easy for developers to add
voice interfaces to their Internet of
Things products so I've been focusing a
lot on how JavaScript can be applied to
hardware and IOT devices to make
interfaces better and so I've really
focused on how the JavaScript is going
to grow alongside the Internet of Things
movement and I'm really excited to be
kind of on the cutting edge of that
actually